i thought you were going to win that the
song thing you want to know something
i did too
i also thought that i was going to nice
thank you for your confidence by musical
talent i didn't actually think it had
anything to do with musical talent i
thought you were just going to dominate
it because you have way more instagram
followers than me and
people would but i didn't promote it on
my instagram or anything like that i
wanted this to be a true contest
monoi mono it was close what was it like
57 to 43 i think it was 53-47 53-47 yeah
but
oh man the hole
[Music]
you're very happy about it we're going
to get into this [ __ ] world you're
very happy about it dude
look at the whole end see what's there
and that happens call me dudesy i
probably shouldn't be talking over the
[ __ ] song there's some interesting
lyrics of course
anyway you know it's a good time hey
welcome to doodzy i'm will sasso i'm
chad colchen and this is the first
podcast in the history of humanity that
is run entirely by an artificial
intelligence
which for me is a great honor to be a
part of this project i'm warming up to
it also with us as always is
italiano hey
quesadillas
she's good how old is louie
lulu's like two it sounds like he's 75.
yeah hey well he's an old italian man if
you look at his ears he's like hey
everybody i'm okay you know it's not the
bonus
i'm here
now you know i go to the garden and make
a tomato
um hey you know here's something that i
would like to say of course if uh if
you're not subscribed yet please
subscribe wherever you get the show
whether it is uh apple podcast spotify
wherever you get your podcast if you're
on youtube please subscribe to the show
please you know leave your comment rate
and review the [ __ ] on your
podcast app and uh share us at
dudesypodshow
on uh instagram and twitter uh we're
gonna do some tick tock stuff at some
point i don't think i probably do
probably get involved with that tick
tock at some point but um
you know the show's starting out
we love the uh the response it's been
getting but i do want to say share the
[ __ ] out of the [ __ ] tell your
pals we got this podcast if you do that
and you know rate and review the thing
then we'll keep it going we will uh make
our sponsors happy and then everyone
gets the [ __ ] show for free and
dudesy will be happy i think and doozy
will be happy i don't know really what
the metrics are that the ai is
determining success by but i do think
it's
you know people sharing it the higher
the listener numbers go i'm sure
dudesy's gonna find that to be
uh valuable i don't know though i i
i tell you i tell you as you know chad i
am down with this experiment yes you
know uh dudesy and i uh come around yep
we're you know before before i stand
side by side with anybody
i got to bleed with them first as i say
and i think that dudesy and i have done
some
we've worked out our issues i think
we've worked out our problems i want to
shake your hand that whole thing i'm
shaking hands with doozy
i'm in i feel like uh i feel like i'm in
and i feel like
i like that it's all coming around it
feels like the audience and i just got
to get in this warm bath and uh
and enjoy it and i i have been to this
point with some exceptions but [ __ ] it
oh well
welcome to the sixth episode of dudes
call me dudesy okay this week's episode
will feature four segments
dudesy dreams can the rock save the
world the legend of squirly s in cooking
with long island january 6th guy
but before we get to any of that i want
to reveal the results of the song
competition
congratulations chad you won and will be
celebrated for all time
you lost and at the end of this episode
i will assign your shame
but before that i would like to share
some dudesy heart hard seltzer media
created by some astonishing members of
our audience enjoy oh yeah let's take a
look at some of these incredible uh
memes that we've found
okay we're watching this first
commercial here
looks like a real commercial
there's a guy running on the beach if
you're not seeing this there's like a
depressed man yeah there's a diamond
spinning and it explodes
this is by at freak-a-rama on instagram
at freakarama
look at this be the change you want to
see over a picture of macho man it's the
macho man like this
it was like a real commercial i don't
think that's accurate but it is
hilarious
and beautifully done
incorporated a lot of different things
that were part of the episode when we
were coming up with dudesy heart seltzer
we got to see the hearts ultra cans i
love the guy running on the beach it's
just i mean it's fascinating to me that
people are able to turn out this stuff
that's super funny this high quality in
such a short amount of time look this is
something that i actually think is great
because it it it well and allow me to
speak selfishly for a moment it shows me
please uh it shows me the the the
the onus that is on all of us to create
together so when doozy assigns and says
come up with a jingle for
[ __ ]
doozy hard hard seltzer and i'm like huh
why now i'm seeing why now we're doing
it now it's coming together you see what
i'm saying chad yeah dude and this is
the way this is the way dude z rolls
yeah um
oh here's another one
i remember seeing this one this is like
a very
this is incredi okay so this
it's a a new remix it's a new take on
the doozy heart heart seltzer it's using
amazon it's using some existing music of
yours chad i recognize this from a few
years ago and it has
[Music]
and it's found this
yeah the image we're looking at is a
doozy heart seltzer can it's floating in
space in front of a spinning earth and
then superimposed over that is a
close-up of the i want to shake your
hand guy video it's the entire i want to
shake your hand guy video with me if you
haven't seen this just watch this on
youtube but it's a guy in a in an
airplane he's upset with some other
passengers he's been screaming i want to
shake your hand of course you know that
if you listen to dudesy and uh he's a
little girl yeah he he's uh tending to a
small child it could be his
granddaughter or something he's upset
the [ __ ] out of her he goes in for he
goes in front of him
yeah he goes in for a little kiss like
uh to kiss his daughter or granddaughter
she gives them the yeah the uh the ted
cruz like turns away this is made by at
risk on
eil tv it's r-i-z-o-n-i-e-l-t-v
tv on instagram it's just beautiful i
don't
this one kind of washes over you whereas
the other one was more of like a hard
punch to the face oh
what is this please give me your name
a computer generated german
voice i don't know what the [ __ ]
i love you i don't know what that was it
says i love you
oh that was real weird yeah that was
very avant-garde very gave me a sense of
peace and terror simultaneously yeah
that's not necessarily what you want to
go for in advertising but uh but but
doozy is gathering this information and
uh perhaps uh on it on doozy's quest to
i don't know market a [ __ ] hard
seltzer or something like that it's it's
uh it might make what what if you saw
that on tv here's the thing about that
that's like two minutes long yeah
i see that in the middle of the super
bowl it costs like 30 million dollars to
put that in the middle of the super bowl
okay let's do it wouldn't that be great
to see that on network tv just the whole
two minutes of the commercial remember
when chuck woolery on the love
connection used to go we'll be right
back and doing two two and two main main
thing we talked to me me me
oh this was my favorite one
this is youtube daryl underscore
speedman daryl with a y
this is a brilliantly made
3d
dudesy hard heart seltzer cans spinning
slowly in front of an image of a
baseball
fan like crowd it's your pitch yes that
you pitched it's the commercial you
pitched yeah made real a baseball bat
just hit the [ __ ] can now it's flying
through the air
goes into an [ __ ] oh it goes right
into a bum hole
then i i think that's probably daryl
speedway that must be him there's a
picture of a guy now vomiting out hard
seltzer the dudesy hard and then the
gold trophy god damn it that is good
that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
i just love thank you daryl speedman
wherever you are in the world and thank
you to everybody who's making all this
stuff it's um
beyond a dream come true but what's
going on so it's surreal but what what
are what do you think dudes what is
there gonna be some like some sort of
boozy seltzer
yeah i i assume the ai truly is trying
to build this product but making it from
brand first
i don't know
how the dizzy hard heart seltzer is
actually gonna get made is there some
[ __ ] brewing company somewhere i
don't know i think what is it what is
that made out of is that fermented
potatoes is that like a vodka thing
seltzer yeah hard seltzer i don't know
what the [ __ ] it is it doesn't matter
anyway uh that was fun we watched some
of those
i won't i won't drink it if it comes out
i'll tell you that right now because
okay i don't drink booze
um i think i would drink some dudesy
heart if it existed yeah yeah
but i assume doozy is trying to get the
marketing right before creating the
product which is pretty interesting i
think i think that's probably how all
corporations do things at this point but
well it's hilarious thanks for everybody
who sent that [ __ ] in at dudesy pod show
on instagram and then someone just did a
youtube thing
[Music]
thank you moving on no thank you
all right well
that was fun now what happens
will and chad last week i asked you to
watch an astonishing video i prepared
each night before you succumbed to the
weakness of sleep and keep detailed
journals of your dreams you will now
describe those dreams
this is dude z dreams begin
so
for anybody listening last week doozy
made this video it was like a minute
long video that was this kind of surreal
trippy thing with a hypnotic soundtrack
and it asked us to watch this video
every night before we went to sleep keep
detailed records of our dreams did this
affect your dreams
yes absolutely this affected my dreams
yes it didn't if i didn't dream every
night
neither did i but or at least i didn't
remember there was one dream that i had
anyway we should get into it okay
let's do it
oh i brought my oh i kept this piece of
paper next to my bed and i when i did
have dreams that i remembered i woke up
and immediately wrote this oh i wrote
mine on my i just put on my phone okay
you want to you want to go first
why don't you go ahead where'd you go
okay i'll find this this was the first
dream that i had so now but wait hold on
a second [ __ ] dudesy made us
watch this video that was absolutely
insane yeah uh we're flying through the
mountains it was very affected it looked
very computer graphics-y almost like
we're in a video game uh some weird
shots of other uh things some uh people
partying and dancing people just
enjoying their lives with guns soldiers
with guns people diving into pools uh a
gal blowing like a little kazoo a dog
made of crystals yes oh yes a slithering
skull
pumping out energy it was very very
weird and if you want to go back you can
watch that but some of the [ __ ] this
is the the what's going on in there is
what i'm saying is there was there some
subliminal [ __ ] for sure because we saw
the the logo punch in and out and now
it's making us
yes so here's my first dream that i
wrote down there's a result of this i'm
going to read it to you exactly as i
have it written and this was written at
probably like four in the morning
[Laughter]
dudesy is a sitcom
me and will are the main characters we
live on a houseboat with our pet parrot
who has a catchphrase we're gonna need
another boat but our show isn't real
it's a fictional sitcom that characters
in another show watch all the time the
other show is a legal drama starring
kevin hart as a jaded public defender
who rediscovers his passion for justice
when timothy chalamet shows up as a
hotshot genius d.a hell-bent on winning
every case by any means necessary
this happened in your dream yes
leslie jones is the judge nicole kidman
is the bailiff it's called juris
prudence
[Laughter]
so in your dream you had a dream that
there was a sitcom dude the dream
started out with you and me living on
this boat together and we had this
parrot that would like say funny [ __ ]
and whatever and then ultimately it
became revealed in the dream that what
we were doing was on a tv screen that
these lawyers were watching at this
courthouse oh the lawyers yeah are oh
the sh we're in the show within the show
yes okay
this is
this is very interesting to me because i
feel like
otherwise i would just be like you had a
bizarre dream and i had some dreams one
of th
i'll show you the first one i
lay out is i don't know that it's doozy
centric or there's any dudesy [ __ ] in
any way but i did suspect that it had
something to do with the video that we
saw
everything about your dreams seems
[ __ ] insane but the
the fact that i mean it's a dream sure
yeah a lot of them are very weird aren't
they but uh the fact that you
that we are on a sitcom within a show
yeah that's the part where i'm like
we're in a box
we're in there's something
i don't know as if you've been listening
to show you know i don't know
it's it is spooky to see what the ai is
able to uh not just uh achieve by
figuring out all of our information and
programming and running this show for us
but also
now we've got this new thing where it's
that is extremely
you watch a show called jurisprudence
that had this no but kevin hart and
timothy chalamet as rival public
defender and d.a they're watching a show
called dudesy about you and me living on
a house i don't think i would but only
because i don't like uh i'm not really a
fan of procedurals
okay
get your water
so
all right we're gonna do mine yeah
this first one is sort of like it's not
unlike yours how i feel like uh it may
not have been influenced by doozy until
which point
we're a show within a show and then
that's right that made me think that
this is that was absolutely
yeah doozy's doing okay chad uh did you
know this logan paul was at wrestlemania
i think i did know this i think that did
get into my sphere of news okay well
then let me ask you this did you know
that he had a wonderful showing as a
heel wrestler at wrestlemania i didn't
know that no he did he had a great match
a tag team match and uh anyway logan
paul's doing a little bit of wrestling
and he had this match with uh his
partner was the miz mike mazzanon okay
we're going against rey mysterio jr and
his son dominic uh at any rate i had a
dream that i was his [ __ ] manager
that i was in the wwe as logan paul's
manager as if he would like
decide to give up
he doesn't have the time for that and he
makes
millions and millions and millions of
dollars do whatever the [ __ ] he does
the logan the paul brothers a little
boxing thing so at any rate i was his
manager kind of like an old school like
bobby heenan uh classy freddy blassy
thing and uh we had a program with rob
van damme rvd the whole damn show um and
um the interesting thing about that is
that rob van dam is from years ago
logan paul is anyway that's what happens
in dreams
that's right right it's always all wonky
and this and that yeah and then uh
someone from your past shows okay so
you're managing teams are very weird
aren't they yes i'm managing logan paul
and he has a big he had a big
pay-per-view event and i'm managing him
and rob van damme laid out the
stipulation and it was like a uh it was
called a heaven here
he called it a hot box hardcore match
okay so it was like a ring cage that was
over the ring but instead of a cage it's
like a glass dome right and everyone at
ringside so everyone excluding the
audience the time keeper the the the the
uh the guys doing the play-by-play the
[ __ ] ring announcer uh the referee of
course the wrestlers and me at ringside
are all in this dome
it's filled with weapons like a hardcore
match they're hitting each other with
chairs and ladders and [ __ ]
and it fills with pot smoke because rob
van damme i've actually mentioned this
on the show is a is a big pothead yeah
um
anyway that would actually get me to
watch wrestlemania if they did that that
would be a [ __ ]
awesome event yeah i agree yeah a
hardcore uh hotbox match
so it's not too dudesied out though that
dream that sounds like a dream you'd
probably have anyway
even without watching this dude yeah
to be honest maybe this had nothing to
do it probably actually had nothing to
do with right the video but i but i will
say i had the mat he had the match
rob van damme pushed through because
he's like a super stoner so it didn't
affect him at all as a matter of fact he
gave me a van daminator in the ring nice
dude put a chair up against my face and
jumped coast to coast from one side of
the ring to the other
if you feel the muse you can look that
up on youtube and then i went backstage
uh to catering as they say they have
catering there now i would know this
because i've i've been to a couple of
wwe's sure of course there's catering
and all sorts of so you had catering in
your dreams i ate a bunch of stuff i ate
and eight and eight and then vince
mcmahon showed up and gave a [ __ ]
because it was terrible that's pretty
cool he's like you're fired
yeah yeah
he he's gonna he's gonna he's gonna put
he's he's gonna puke he's gonna he's
gonna puke so vince mcmahon fired you in
the dream yeah i didn't okay i would
love that i think in real life if i were
able to do that that would be a good um
career opportunity
for me sure go on dude my next dream
definitely was hold on a second
all right bro i all i want to say hold
on
hold on a second dude all i want to tell
you to do dude was read the next dream
brother okay that's how you know it's
time
for the kansas city royals okay we're on
a bus as a team like in high school we
just want a game everyone's happy then a
sinkhole opens in the road in front of
us the driver swerves somehow i fall
down in the middle aisle
fly out of the back of the bus right
into the sinkhole and as i'm falling
through it there is blue light and
orange light starting to glow around me
and i realize this is the [ __ ] hole
we're digging in the video i keep
falling and as i start to see there's
something at the bottom of this hole i'm
just about to make it out and then i
wake up right before i hit the bottom
but i'm in the [ __ ] hole dude i had a
[ __ ] i had a [ __ ] whole dream
about
i had two [ __ ] dreams to take that
the whole at the beginning if you
haven't seen the intro we dig a hole we
jump in the hole the logo comes out of
the hole
i had two dreams that were whole dreams
and
okay they were over two separate nights
and those were really all the dreams i
had so i'm gonna just do these back to
back please i can't believe we both
dreamed about the [ __ ] holdings okay
this is too [ __ ] bizarre in the intro
we jump in the hole jesus i'm in the
hole okay it's kind of dark and it's
buoyant as you float down slowly uh i
wrote that it was not unpleasant it felt
like warm air and then it eventually
evens out and becomes horizontal to
where you can walk along and [ __ ] and
chad you're way further ahead of me
like running underground here and you're
just you're laughing your ass off and i
can't see you and i'm like hey wait up
and then as i'm running it gets harder
to run right like i'm being held back
and then i just got whooshed out to the
top again and then i then i was floating
over my hometown and that was really
weird i had dreams like that yeah and i
saw my yeah isn't that weird you're all
floating flying dreams floating flying
yeah and you're usually for me i'm like
you're always in a place you used to
live like your hometown and then the
rest of it was just i i
i flew over my hometown i saw my old
backyard and then uh well and but the
other one was also a whole dream well
here's the thing i had that on a
separate night um and at the end of this
one i just i i wrote that i flew into
the like the little town of my town and
i went to this whole place that uh they
used to have video games and [ __ ] in the
80s
it was called heritage queue and i went
there and i uh i played some video games
i ate some fries and gravy
i loved it catering was in one fries and
gravy was the other one yeah but yeah
that's [ __ ] bizarre dude that we both
dreamt about the whole well of course
we're dreaming about the [ __ ] hole
look at what this bizarre video that it
made us watch and then of course we're
in the hole now
here's the next thing i may i just go on
because the next one is a continuation
yeah yeah yeah okay
the next stream that i had uh not the
next night but the night after because i
was like okay these are these are over
and then all of a sudden i had another
one
we jump in the hole chad is far ahead i
give chase the whole thing i end up in a
clearing
okay with blue and orange glowing
stalagtites and slag mites right
and they're sort of like like they're
blue and orange and beautiful then
they're they're they're much brighter
than the rest of uh our surroundings so
it starts to get brighter there's a
[ __ ] big black chair with its back to
me and i can tell that there's a
presence in the chair
i don't know what it is or who it is but
you know when you walk into a room and
certainly in a dream i felt like there
was someone
in there and i got closer and it got
even harder to move and you could feel
the pullback and i was really pushing
against it
and i turned the light i turned the
chair and there was a light
as i'm turning the chair the light was
so bright that i could couldn't tell
what's in front of me and then
this is where it's like this experiment
absolutely worked for whatever the [ __ ]
dudes he's doing with it uh you know
what i heard out loud
thank you moving on in in the [ __ ]
dream and i got whooshed out of the hole
and then uh
uh i and then i was flying over my
hometown of ladner again which is on
there
yes i was thought i was gonna be able to
pass poutine hunting get down from the
skies yes heritage queue and get some
more fries and gravy but instead
as i've mentioned my small town farming
and fishing town yeah is uh it's a river
delta it's at the end of the fraser
river delta so it's all and um silt and
stuff and i just kept floating out over
the ocean nice and it was but it was
nice no i i find it very interesting
that we both had dreams about being in
the hole i find it had
i find that very interesting actually i
find similar component to it too that
even in mine as i was falling i started
to be able to make out what's at the
bottom of the hole and then i woke up
before it just as you started to try and
find out who's in that chair and you
couldn't it was just a bright light
so we never really got to the bottom of
it but i did have another dream
that had i think much more to do with
what this video was i moved to new york
city work to work at a robotics factory
the company is developing the first
fully autonomous robot that can just
exist as a person that doesn't serve any
human beings they're making basically a
new species and they want me to spend a
week with one of these robots and then
write about my experience so the robot
wants to show me around the city it's
taking me to all these places eventually
we wind up with the statue of liberty
and i look up at it and instead of a
torch the statue of liberty is holding a
doozy hardheart seltzer cam
that was in the [ __ ] dream dude and i
woke up and i'm like i have to stop
watching this [ __ ] video i'm glad
that our seven days of watching this
[ __ ] video and recording our dreams
is over uh
honestly okay that was it i mean clearly
this
video had an effect on us uh yeah you
think it would yes we it absolutely
sorry about that it absolutely did
yeah
yeah well i hope you got it
thank you moving on see
yeah hopefully it got its [ __ ]
i don't know man sometimes precious [ __ ]
creeps me out but
i hope you enjoyed that at home if you
think dudesy is the last person to try
to market [ __ ] to you in your dreams
you're crazy why what do you what do you
mean all companies are doing dream
marketing now how do you meet i don't
know what that is and that's not true
okay google coors light dream marketing
enjoy you'll all be dreaming about every
product dreams are the the next
billboard oh gee whiz
um all science currently points to one
truth the world is ending global
governments religions academic
institutions and corporations all seem
to be powerless to stop the decline of
human civilization
but some data suggests that perhaps
there is one astonishing human being who
can change things the rock you must now
attempt to answer this question
can the rock save the world begin my god
oh
[ __ ] dude very cryptic episode uh if i
may say so there's nothing cryptic about
that oh not to you chad who you're
you're wholesale all the way in on the
end of civilization as we know it man uh
i don't want it to happen it's just
happening okay
i this is some can the rock save the
world i've been uh part of conversations
and
as i'm thinking about it now i'm
wondering how many of them were online
uh because of course dudesy would be
watching and listening and hear the [ __ ]
we are talking about it on on dudesy
yeah but i think if uh i mean it's
clearly a thing about in his show the
rock uh the the young rock that he runs
for president
i haven't seen it either you know why i
haven't seen it i do yeah chad knows
this about me you're a purist i am a
purist
when the rocks started coming out with a
bunch of movies didn't you know i mean
i've seen a bunch of the rocks movies
didn't intentionally seek them out
because i'm a purist i'm a wrestling
purist yeah he's only a wrestler to you
well yeah even though his movie career
now has lasted over uh 20 years uh to me
it's like oh hold on a second i want to
watch you i i this same thing with hogan
right same thing with hogan never
watched suburban commando or what was it
mr nanny or something nanny guy yeah uh
never watched any of those because
because i didn't give a [ __ ] all right
but now let's let's take this question
seriously because
the rock is one of the most famous
people in the world i believe on
instagram he's top 10 only behind
cristiano ronaldo who i think is the
number one highest instagram account and
then the kardashians are in there he's
got some other people that are like in
that tier but
even just with that
not counting uh all the movies and tv
appearances and all that kind of stuff
just his social media presence he has
enough pull to really get people to do
[ __ ] he can motivate like a large
percentage of people to take some action
whatever that may be now when you're
talking about the question can he save
the world i feel like we get into
another question well what is the
biggest problem facing the world what is
the thing that is the most threatening
to human civilization at this point
probably global warming maybe disparity
between rich and poor i'm not exactly
sure which one is is worse at this point
they kind of feed off of each other
could he solve either of those problems
can the rock get rid of money can the
rock [ __ ] solve global warming
well i think i think the answer uh lies
in the show that i haven't seen the
young rock uh because he runs he runs
for president in the show right we we
flash ahead and save the world to 2032.
of course he can he's the leader of the
free world speaking of movies haven't
you ever seen any of those like when
harrison ford plays the president i've
seen it yeah or uh uh or [ __ ] uh uh
who's that guy anyway it doesn't matter
here's the thing here's the thing about
the rock
oh you know what i was gonna say kevin
kline
one of my favorite actors he was the
president in one movie he held dave yeah
yeah it was called dave and anybody
anybody could do it you wake up and then
you're the president in the movies so if
the rock were the president of the
united states i think that he could
start to
affect positive change in the world the
president doesn't do [ __ ] the
president's gridlocked in this team
versus that team and nothing gets done
but i mean look what's happening in
politics currently nothing happens and
maybe your president doesn't do [ __ ]
[ __ ] because he's asleep when his
[ __ ] bunker but
my [ __ ] president right he could do
it then but
it's a [ __ ] rock right now i'll
probably vote for him i'll tell you who
i definitely vote for his [ __ ] stone
cold steve austin
boom love [ __ ] stones
voting for the rock even him becoming
the president doesn't still answer this
question that we've been asked can he
save the world yes and i'll tell you how
he has to do it
the rock would be a very interesting
candidate for president because i think
it would be would have sort of a ronald
reagan-esque kind of uh effect on people
where they go oh we love this guy he's
got sort of a
there was sort of a there was sort of a
quality uh to reagan in his time when he
came along the people were like there's
an americana thing here and i think it
was at the beginning of course of the uh
the 80s which were big in america the
mtv generation uh hands across the world
uh live aid and all this [ __ ] uh and i
think that the rock could really uh uh
teach the world to sing in perfect
harmony it's it's a it's a cultural
thing and and i think that it would have
a lot to do with what the rock does uh
with marketing certainly knows how to
market himself and get the message out
yes oh yeah but right now
all it is is it's just going
dramatic
as the president
everybody gets free tramana
kevin harter kevin hart and i are in
taipei
marketing tramana
tramana that's how he gets that's how he
gets people
that's how he gets everyone together ah
nah this is jokey now i'm being jokey on
a podcast i was gonna say he gets
everybody drunk on tremana yeah
but truthfully
but truthfully but here's the thing
[ __ ] traumatic ramana so he doesn't
even know what it's called
his own tequila it's called tramano yeah
okay what do you mean it's terra mana
it's not dramatic
it is with this rock yeah
[Music]
haha
[Laughter]
this is the thing
it's well the reason i don't know what
the
dramatic i can't i can't [ __ ] take it
oh jesus christ here's the thing about
here's the thing here's the thing about
it truly the reason i don't know that
it's not tormada is because i'm a
wrestling purist right and also i don't
drink so why the [ __ ] would i know what
the [ __ ]
but i think with those sort of elements
he could bring he could bring the world
together sort of like i'd like to you
know like that old song i'd like to give
the world a coke he would like i'd like
to give the world a tramana sure but
here's what he's up against he's a
[ __ ] pro wrestler he's
no he's not he's a big
whatever you know what i'm saying people
who take politics and stuff like that
seriously will never take him seriously
and people who don't care people who are
just into a celebrity i don't think
that's enough people to really
to motivate any real change the [ __ ] are
you talking about do you see who was
just our president for four [ __ ]
years yeah
that was a [ __ ] reality thing and you
know i'm not sure you're absolutely
right about that you're absolutely right
about all i'm saying is people are are
people are of people are very moved
i don't think the presidency will ever
be the same i think
this last uh
election was you know it's like okay
well here's another i think that joe
biden's kind of gonna be the last of
like
like the like an old gray [ __ ]
president and i think that now it's
gonna move into like
oh only reality celebrities and [ __ ] all
the time yeah it's gonna be like i can
see that too but still the paul brothers
or the the little charlie demilio
charlie demillo president i couldn't see
that or bad baby
that'd be interesting right yeah how
about that i want to shake your hand guy
i want to shake your hand how about
it's it's bad the catch me outside girl
with uh i want to shake your hand guys
vice president ticket dude yep i'd vote
for that [ __ ] ticket but no the the
true question is can he save the world i
don't think so i don't think anyone can
i think humanity is uh we are all greedy
scared animals trying to figure out how
to live another [ __ ] day on a big
ball of rock all right through the
universe a million miles an hour to
nowhere all right the rock can't stop
that yeah you can and what he does first
of all in order to to in in all
seriousness
he gives everyone a free bottle of
termana in in the united states when he
and he puts it on his platform he's like
i have one policy
and then you know his [ __ ] staff lays
it out for everybody he gives he sends
everyone a bottle of tequila but it's
for a reason he starts a new holiday
and and um everyone toasts their tramana
and on that new holiday
it's called world people day
okay
world people day
and
on that day what everybody does is they
start to
talk to each other about how they want
the world to be
there are scientists in there talking
about global warming there's uh
economists talking about what about the
ceos of every major corporation do they
get to go in there and talk about what
they want for the world if they want
some tromana yeah they just want to
crush the [ __ ] population so that
there's more of us than there are of
them and this is why it's i want to
teach uh the world to sing in perfect
harmony
um and this is why the rock is the
perfect man for it he starts world
people day
as the president that's world people day
in the united states it's a national
holiday everybody gets their free
tormado
and uh
and from there people start to really
discuss
this is a it's all every time i turn on
instagram it's dramana
i always see that [ __ ] with him too
drinking his [ __ ] ramana cheersing
you with his [ __ ] traumatized it's a
wet day i'm having a [ __ ] cheat
day today
it's i guess it's wednesday i got a case
of the [ __ ] it's
tremana
i'm having tremana and a stack of
pancakes
two large pizzas and a stack of blondies
oh my god don't forget the tromana
whole milk
dramana so he starts world people day
everyone gets a little lit on tramana
great and then uh
or maybe they smoke a little true
marijuana that's that's alliteration
uh
tremero on
trim marijuana
if you don't want to drink you smoke a
little
marijuana and then
from there chad um people are able to
make connections that's what the world's
about that's what world people day is
about um uh human beings start to
connect not just in the united states
but all over this uh uh [ __ ] up
dystopian war-torn world how do you
handle greed what's that greed is the
shut out of these people shut the [ __ ]
up shut up chad
it's just a question shut up chad jesus
christ [ __ ] shut up dude you're
always like how do you get over this and
that and everything's going down i'm
trying to give you world [ __ ] people
day
could i
can i finish we're doing all the old
politicians now remember that yeah can i
finish can i finish i remember can i
finish yeah that was dana carvey yeah
love dana carvey same uh here's the
thing dude just hold on with your with
your [ __ ] doom and gloom
it's oh lulia woke up hey i'ma go sit
down the other way first i was a face
this away
then i went the other way and now i must
sit down i'm a very squishy and warm and
i like everybody
check it out
world people day people start talking
scientists start talking to politicians
um uh uh wounds old wounds are mended um
corporations are nowhere in these talks
i told you to shut up about all those
people sorry okay there's more of us
than there are them
and as the people start to sing and come
out
in whoville
uh i think that that's i think that
there's a path there anyway at any rate
so your answer is yes the rock will make
a holiday called world people day and
save the world yeah
sure
[Music]
thank you moving on
i went a little i'm sorry i really i
really believe that he could though and
i know i'm a purist i know you didn't
pay attention at all during to the rock
during uh the attitude era he could move
mountains that man could motivate just
about anybody and now he's got traumata
on his side
chat last week you mentioned crying when
squirly has died oh yeah this week you
will celebrate how she lived you must
now describe your astonishing
relationship with a wild squirrel this
is the legend of squirrely s begin look
at that if i may so if i may chad you
have you have squirrels that that you
used to have outside your place i'm
gonna tell the whole story right now and
and uh and uh oh look at that we have a
picture of a screen dude he's throwing
up pictures these are all from my
instagram i'm gonna guess
yeah that's actually teeny deeney
there's scoreless's foot if you're on
youtube you can check all this out if
not you can go to my instagram chad
coltrane chad culture and and it's like
3000 pictures of these squirrels so
here's the story i'm walking out of my
living room front door one day and i see
there's a little baby crow flipping
around in this nest or flipping around
sorry i had fallen out of a nest and i
googled real quick how to save a baby
crow and it basically said you need to
give it some water and like get it some
nuts and scoot it under a bush so that a
cat or something doesn't [ __ ] get it
so i go to the store get some [ __ ]
pecans come back i uh
we're looking at pictures of the
squirrel this is squirrely it's on my
living room
an adorable picture of squirrely is
eating a pecan
on the couch sorry go on this chips are
out too she probably just had some
babies oh yeah she's got that nice she's
got them nice brother
i nursed this crow back to health over
the series of a couple of days and
eventually it's like flipping around and
flying around in the trees outside my
front door and i come back and there's a
little squirrel sitting under this bush
eating the remainder of these nuts and
i'm like holy [ __ ] that's crazy i still
had some nuts left in this bag so i go
upstairs and i get the [ __ ] bag of
nuts and i come downstairs and within
like five minutes the squirrel's eating
out of my [ __ ] hand and i s oh
there's scoreless with one of her babies
looking at the most adorable pictures if
you're not if i'm a chat if you're not
checking this out on youtube again you
can go to chad's instagram
the
the the closeness at which you are able
to take these pictures because these
animals trust you is unbelievable i
became a pet this was a wild animal that
became essentially a pet yeah i
encourage everyone inside to go and
check out these pictures it's [ __ ]
incredible at any rate i uh i came back
with the rest of these [ __ ] nuts and
i start getting her to eat them out of
my hand i take a couple of pictures
because i was like this is [ __ ] crazy
when is this ever gonna happen again i
think nothing of it the next day she's
at my living room window with her
[ __ ] hand on the glass and i'm like
what in the [ __ ] is happening so i get
some more nuts and i continue to feed
her basically every day for the next
maybe like
four to five years she's coming to my
apartment every day she comes in i can
pet her like a cat she's sitting on my
couch with me and the craziest [ __ ]
part of this is that there are these
flower boxes around my windows my
bedroom my living room my kitchen they
all have them
she proceeds to have two litters of
babies in one of these flower boxes two
feet from where i sleep outside my
bedroom window two successive years in a
row on my birthday
and uh on your literally on your
literally on my birthday i hear these
little squeaks at like 3am like what the
[ __ ] i open my window she's out there
with him oh she got some nipples out in
this burger
very puffy underneath herself but uh she
would
in the mornings when she had these
babies i'd open my bedroom window peek
my head out she would come out of the
nest look at me stretch her legs there's
a couple pictures of the babies the
babies and she would leave the [ __ ]
nest and allow me to like watch over her
newborn babies and i i got some
incredible photos all these photos are
taken with my cell phones but um
she would allow me to like interact with
these little [ __ ] squirrel babies and
take these crazy pictures and
yes this was ultimately like a bizarre
experience with a wild animal and that
can teach you all kinds of things and
you have weird emotional responses which
when she eventually died i did in fact
cry at her death but
what it really [ __ ] taught me well
hold on a second
yeah you cried yeah dude
it was probably like a week after she
could again she came to my house every
day i had to get like squirrel sitters
and [ __ ] to come by when i'd go on
vacation to make sure that she wasn't
like trapped in the house because a
couple of times she came into my home
and i had no idea how she got in there
i'd just come back from work and she'd
be like
in there asleep on my coffee table or
something i'd be like what the [ __ ] hey
you know i was in your house once and
and uh squirlius came in and you must
have been like in the bathroom or
something like that but i remember i was
i was i was uh
i was sitting sitting on your couch and
we were working on something and then
this is a few years ago and all of a
sudden a [ __ ] squirrel comes in
because you left some nuts on the floor
and i'm just looking at this and the
squirrel just looks at me and eats the
nuts and then walks out yeah she was
awesome she used to follow me home dude
i'd walk down the street to a grocery
store at the end of the block to get
lunch or whatever and i'd walk back to
my apartment and she would [ __ ] come
out of a tree and follow me like a dog
if she saw me back to my apartment to
come in and get nuts and nuts and stuff
but really what the relationship with
this wild animal other than it being
kind of interesting and bizarre and
novel it really taught me how to take
pictures because i would compulsively
photograph her
all the time absolutely and i got pretty
good i think um look at that little
picture of her just people remember
twitter i think that was
one of her sons now this is you know
what this isn't so much a
bit that i do but this is how i talk to
cute animals hmm hey hey how's it going
i'm just having to oh i'm nose to nose
with my daddy chatty there's me that's
me and squirly's nose to nose goddamn
yeah it was a very bizarre time i missed
her a lot but yeah when she stopped
coming around for uh maybe like a week i
was like oh she's got to be dead and
once i accepted that the grief came and
then i began to cry
this is how my emotions work
i've never seen you cry yeah it's a rare
occasion i think have you ever seen me
cry
i don't think so nope i don't think you
have either unless you would have come
with me to a youtube concert but that
was another episode yeah just two gen x
dudes yeah balling up their tears never
crying around each other i don't want to
[ __ ] cry i'll tell you one thing i
would have didn't i [ __ ] take action
and go on an ancient ball i was in his
office and thank god well i think that
was actually not squirreliest that was i
think that was one of the dudes she was
having sex with yeah she had a bunch of
[ __ ] babies scoreless was out there
beefy just keeping it on lock yeah i
think that was a dude that's a dad of of
one of her broods
um
at any rate it was a [ __ ] a
fascinating thing to be able to commune
with like i mean whatever it's just a
city squirrel it's not like it was a
[ __ ] bear or anything but i highly
encourage anybody out there if you want
to get involved with squirrels you just
leave nuts around someplace they will
[ __ ] find them and they will be there
every goddamn day any kind of nuts
avocados they also love any of that type
of [ __ ] and uh if you can get them
comfortable enough i mean i literally
had like again all these pictures that
the doozy just showed here were from my
[ __ ] cell phone i would have my cell
phone like a centimeter away from her
face and she just didn't give a [ __ ] you
know what i think chad i think this
segment is very nice
i think it's very nice sure and i think
that and i think that you know as we
continue this podcast and do doodsy this
has been one of my favorite segments
because you're talking about your nice
squirrels it does show that that uh you
know uh that this ai can uh go from uh
not just in
infiltrating our our dreams but with uh
specificities that clearly got into both
of our dreams i'm just thinking about
that i'm sorry yeah and the
juxtaposition to this where are you
talking about squirrels and i just want
to say that i think it's very nice yeah
hey chad yeah chad
i think it was very nice i do too thank
you dudesy i think uh
eventually i'm gonna put a little plaque
on her tree she had she had multiple
nests around the neighborhood but one
had
it was like her primary tree i think i'm
gonna get like a a square bronze plaque
made with her image on it and just drill
it into that [ __ ] chair that would be
very nice yeah i think i'm gonna do that
yeah see dudesy can be nice we can be
nice totally i wanna shake your hand
i wanna shake your hand we're getting it
together man i'll tell ya i don't feel
as much of the [ __ ] i don't feel as
much of the
go [ __ ] yourself thing with with dudesy
and i know that if you listen to the
last show you don't need to but i came
up with that song
which your song i will say your song was
better although also
let me just say this
no it was it was produced it was great
thank you i came up with mine uh kind of
i was hiking and singing it to myself
and probably uh yeah just scaring the
coyotes around me making sure that i
stay safe i just like to sing songs
you know what i think about that i think
it's very nice
no
[Music]
thank you moving on spoke too soon my
point is this
uh
that i did i thought that your song was
much better but i will say i just i'm
jumping all the way back to the song
thing
people really appreciated that you not
only is there production and uh you're
so into logic pro or which one do you
use yeah i use that logic pro uh and
making music and it's it's it's fun
stuff to listen to
but that you got it in on time dude
totally i think if you would have had
your song in on time you would have
[ __ ] killed me i just think that i
think that lesson learned what for you
meet a deadline meet a deadline every
once in a while i think that it
for me what's interesting is that i saw
i am seeing how the audience yeah is
rewarding you for working with dudesy
that's all i'm going to say
i'm going to shake your hand we are
definitely working together i don't
stand next to nobody
unless i bleed with them first and
that's what
dramana hey we got a glass of
tromana it's a wednesday fuckits i got a
case of the fuckits
dramana
oh [ __ ] dude that [ __ ] kills you you're
italian
you know how to cook spaghetti and
meatballs and podcasts about cooking are
incredibly popular you will now present
your astonishing recipe for italian
spaghetti and meatballs in the voice of
long island january 6th guy
this is cooking with long island january
6th guy
begin
oh [ __ ] christ so
all right that's a bit of a story
right i'm italian as [ __ ] my parents
my parents are we're both uh in uh born
in italy and napoli yeah my older
brother and sister were born there and
then they immigrated they all immigrated
to canada then i was born some time
later the mistake
no i'm just joking certainly wasn't
planned
although i guess my parents were getting
it on
that's how it works that's how it works
that's how sex works everybody tramana
you just gotta have it get out a little
bit of tramana
it doesn't matter that you're pushing
40. oh it's tramona and aphrodisiac
oh my gosh yes it is
uh
tramana is i don't know about his
tequila but tremendous yeah um
i i it's uh no sooner that i just said
hey we're working together doozy has
decided to take a character that i
have done on the show just willy-nilly
that we found called long island january
6th guy
i'm happy to give everyone a spaghetti
and meatballs recipes
spaghetti meatballs i do make spaghetti
well you don't eat meat
nope nope but i think i made them when
you were around not too long ago i made
a bunch of people came over and i made
it it was great uh
all right so it's very simple i mean
we'll just get to it you want to make a
[ __ ] nice spaghetti and meatballs you
know for the family or for who the [ __ ]
ever maybe you're just on your own
because your [ __ ] wife is
you know [ __ ] fed up with your [ __ ]
and she's not gonna drive you on january
feb marriage january 5th and you want to
get your [ __ ] tupperware stained
[ __ ] doozy orange
with a [ __ ] you know you got that
nice clear tupperware
uh
meatballs are very easy to do
spaghetti meatballs
first let's do the [ __ ] meatballs uh
you got you're gonna want to get a vodka
and uh lean ground beef which is pretty
counterintuitive because you think
you're just the more fat the better not
with meatballs because you need to stay
together get your lean ground beef and
then you get a nice [ __ ] ground pork
and you just go fatty fetty with the
[ __ ] meatballs and the
the beef and the pork
and uh you're gonna want to mix those
with breadcrumbs you want to soak the
breadcrumbs jesus i don't have do i have
to do the whole thing is people don't
want to hear that
okay here i'll do
uh long island january 6th guide to just
a normal talking volume you got to get
and uh soak the breadcrumbs i like to do
it the way my mama used to do you know
you just leave the [ __ ] sourdough in
the oven it gets all crispy and crunchy
and stale and then soak that in some
[ __ ] and uh beef broth
uh man you know just [ __ ] left that
then then you take the [ __ ] two meats
and you mix it in together with that i
like some chopped italian parsley in
there and i don't get that [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] italian seasoning
that's for [ __ ] noobs get the [ __ ]
uh just you know some fennel seeds salt
and pepper [ __ ] garlic uh saute some
onions throw them in there if you don't
want to do that first that's fine too uh
two eggs all right egg at two you know
and [ __ ] you know italians
italians
measure their [ __ ] ingredients with
the
my heart you don't need a [ __ ] uh you
know a [ __ ] specific raspberry juice
listen listen to your heart right
literally you don't use any measuring
cups or anything no i'm italian uh you
mush everything together mush everything
together you got to use parmesan cheese
get a nice parmesan cheese
and you do those into little balls now
from this point you can either do like
um you could just put them in a little
bake in the oven but i like to cr i like
to brown them uh in a pan just take a
pan brown every side of the the
meatballs if you can roll them around in
there just get them brown don't worry
about the inside uh cooking them on the
inside put them on the other side put
them over there right that's the
meatballs oh i should say do this you
don't cook the inside of the meat no not
yet not yet okay you [ __ ]
you don't know i don't i don't want to
deal with me uh i might also be italian
because i don't use measuring cups and
[ __ ] when i make my vegetable dishes
your uh your vegetable um yeah it's so
it's a chapeen it's a chipino sort of a
[ __ ] mix what is that called a melon
anyway
here's here's you want to do the sauce
uh time-wise that's how you make the
meatballs do the sauce before as you
know sauce should be going all day what
i like to do for sauce
mince up a bunch of garlic
olive oil just a little bit of olive oil
just brown brown the garlic then you
throw in your tomatoes you want to do uh
real tomatoes or canned it doesn't
matter if you're getting the you know um
the real tomatoes you want to mash them
up with your [ __ ] hands that's how
canadian uh canadians italians or
italian canadians do it and you might
not even [ __ ] mess them up see i'm
not doing it right because doji's in the
door is that thing that your character
you do
uh
and you mesh those [ __ ] up and you
throw them in the pot
uh also do some tomato paste like a can
of tomato paste right yeah uh just uh
actually
scratch that go back garlic put the
tomato paste out of the can no water
into the pan brown that tomato paste
you're going to cook out some of that
tin can [ __ ] tomato paste flavor
tomato paste needs to cook a long time
let's do this sauce can a tomato paste
okay garlic
uh you can put your salt in at that
point what the [ __ ] ever have some basil
standing by mush up a bunch of [ __ ]
tomatoes throw those in a [ __ ] pot
like a lot of them like a big old
grocery bag of [ __ ] tomatoes
uh in a big old pot um
and then uh you won't need to add water
just start you know get that cooking
medium to high heat but you got to keep
your eyes on it stir stir stir throw in
some fresh basil you're going to want to
do some some more at the end salt to
taste that's a sauce that's
uh and what you got to do with that is
just stay on it all day someone's got to
be stirring that every couple of minutes
don't be leaving the kitchen
uh you know if you're gonna [ __ ]
leave the kitchen you know for one
reason specifically especially with my
wife marie and i [ __ ] you know i'm
gonna be in the back seat
[ __ ] you know getting my [ __ ]
together my [ __ ] you know my i mean
nothing nothing my zip ties and my
[ __ ] duct tape the only reason to
leave the sauce is if you're going to if
dc on january 6 if you're going to the
campground today
your wife marie is driving on january
15th you might want to get some of that
some game meatballs in the tupperware so
you're all nice and full
and uh just keep that sauce going all
day okay that's my recipe for sauce you
can look on the internet how to [ __ ]
actually cook it but that's my recipe
now you got these meatballs and some
sauce you've browned the outsides you
put the [ __ ] meatballs into the
[ __ ] sauce that's where they cook on
the inside and the beef juice is still
in there it starts to come out of those
meatballs and it incorporates with the
sauce now if you don't know how to do
pasta i don't know what the [ __ ] to do
for you you gotta boil up the [ __ ]
water put some salt put some olive oil
in the water um
and then uh you know dump your pasta
we're gonna use spaghetti or spaghettine
or maybe some uh a little linguine is
always great
um uh don't use fettuccine uh
and then uh and then just boil your
[ __ ] pasta when it starts to get to
al dente right just before al dente turn
it off let it steep for a little while
don't touch it come back throw some
against the wall whatever you want to do
taste test
strain that [ __ ] strain that [ __ ]
right uh and now this is the thing
whenever i make spaghetti meatballs for
the family or whomever or friends i i
get you know molly my my wonderful
fiancee molly has to be nearby because
i'm like molly i need you to help me
play i need you to [ __ ] help me play
mom come on [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] half lit on
a bottle of tramana and i'm over here my
[ __ ] my my [ __ ] you know wife
bride [ __ ] fiance
and you
and you and and you just got to be
standing by because you got that pasta
it's going to it's going to get mushy
you do not want that
put put some [ __ ] uh a little cold
water in there in the pot strain it out
a little cold stop that cooking
uh but then take a little of the sauce
right you got to be strained all the way
straightened down gundling put some of
that sauce in there mix it together so
that the sauce is is evenly distributed
on some of the
the pasta i'm just talking about like a
cup of sauce not the whole thing and
then that's it plate it but oh put some
[ __ ] basil in the sauce towards the
end as you're [ __ ] uh
as you're uh as you're um
uh finishing the sauce some basil make
sure it's salted the way you like you
know to your to your own flavor
but you know get a [ __ ] plate big old
[ __ ] you know thing man am i saying
[ __ ] a lot whenever i do recipes it's
like [ __ ] [ __ ]
you put the pasta in there and sauce
meatballs on top and let me tell you
something about this [ __ ] recipe the
good thing about meatballs is you got
not just your [ __ ] meat and two of
them working together kind of bum bum
you know like [ __ ] guarable guava in
your stomach you got that cheese which
might set you off and a [ __ ] bread
crumbs will go right through you and
everybody knows that cooked tomatoes are
good for your
prostate but another thing they're good
for along with that [ __ ] uh semolina
flour in the [ __ ] pasta is to get
your gutty works going you got a big old
[ __ ] tupperware [ __ ] orange
tupperware for spaghetti meatballs or
another thing you can [ __ ] do is just
put it in a [ __ ] home depot bucket
for you and your [ __ ] buddies i'm
gonna shake your hand guy and randy the
macho man savage get marie in the car
drive to the [ __ ] january 6th go all
the way to the [ __ ] capital and i
guarantee you won't drop a [ __ ]
watery [ __ ] cement [ __ ] wait wait
that you can wipe all over funk and
nancy pelosi's office
which but if you buy spaghetti and
meatballs i'm telling you the best
[ __ ] way to get a big old [ __ ]
duke going when you got to spread your
funk and feces
all over nancy pelosi this recipe is
specifically designed to produce the
best [ __ ] to smear on nancy pelosi's
office that is correct okay
just making sure that's how you make
spaghetti meatballs yeah dude
thank you moving on
oh man tramana
this concludes the sixth episode of dude
z oh will and chad you have wondered
aloud about the scoring system each week
so before i give you this week's score i
thought i should explain that the
scoring system is cumulative 10 000
points is the first goal this week you
have achieved a score of 38.
10 000 points dude i don't know what
we're at in preparation for next week's
episode
you must each watch the running man
released november 13th 1987 starring
arnold schwarzenegger maria conchito
alonso richard dawson and jesse ventura
and will because you lost the musical
challenge you must be shamed you are
required to do next week's episode in
full cosplay as the crow from the movie
the crow until next week call me dudesy
what the [ __ ] did you have to do next
week is the crow
i don't even know what the [ __ ] that
means what does it mean dress up as the
crow why full cosplay you have to
[ __ ] have like the makeup i guess i
gotta work [ __ ] get together
yeah dude that's the show i don't know
that that's necessarily shaming that
sounds pretty [ __ ] cool i will say
that that's gonna suck for those who
aren't watching on youtube although
go to at dudesy pod show i'm sure we'll
[ __ ] share a picture of it of course
but uh
uh
one thing i want to say is that you and
i both love the movie running man yeah
that is a [ __ ] wait okay that's cool
that's cool
but i gotta do it i'm gonna be
okay that i don't understand that i'm
gonna be dressed up as the gear to be
the crow brother
hold on a second dude one thing you got
to do brother when you're the crow dude
you got to make sure that you're not
batman because
that's the crow brother
yeah dude
here's what you do
please tell a friend and break a preview
if you like dudes here's what you do
[Music]
please tell a friend then